hi my name is Samuel Leeds and I am
super excited and honored to be speaking
at the bath property meet very soon I
really hope you can join us
I'm the best-selling author of the
bottom by low rent hi and I've been in
property now since 2008 and have been
financially free for a very long time
I love property and my strategy is
mostly consists of HMOs and lease option
agreement I'm going to be explaining it
back why I think that most people that
do HMOs do it completely wrong and how
you can double or maybe even triple your
return on investment by investing Levi
low rent hi Wayne I'm also going to be
touching on the lease option agreements
as well giving you some magic formulas
which will skyrocket your success in
property and give me the exact tools and
steps that you need to become
financially free very very quickly so if
it sounds too good to be true
come and heckle me on the day we'll have
some fun and we're going to have a Q&A
at the end as well which I'm really
excited about you will walk away with a
clear action plan and I can't wait to be
there so book on now and I'll see you in
math
[Music]